it's still for many people unimaginable
but imagine for a moment that Donald
Trump vodacom precedent of the United
States of America would that be quite a
call the end of American democracy or
the beginning of refreshment of American
democracy ah one never knows but I don't
think it will be the end I mean I think
it's somewhat depends on how it Donald
Trump governs I mean one thing I can say
is that I don't think we know very much
about Donald Trump which is one of the
things that's scary about it but also
one of the things that's exciting about
it um ah you know I think one of the
mistakes people make is that if they
want to understand Hitler they don't
read Hitler you should read my comp a
lot of it was in there um so go and read
the art of the deal which is the book
Donald Trump rope it's not mine health
it's not great literature uh but um I
think you can see page by page step by
step what he's doing as a presidential
candidate it's a book about a
businessman who has a chip on his
shoulder uh who wants to make deals
because he thinks it's fun he actually
has fun making deals and he takes very
seriously the fun about bringing people
together and saying you're gonna sell
this guy that he's gonna sell you this
and you know some of you this and then
she know he makes it happen right is he
a brilliant businessman I don't know
he's lost a lot of money he's wait a lot
of money he inherited somebody I'm not
involved in that I don't care but I
don't think Donald Trump's an ideal odd
I don't think he's a racist I don't
think we're gonna have um a terribly
ideologically racist country if Donald
Trump is our president I do think Donald
Trump um is impulsive narcissistic a
boorish in the sense of being mean and
not very high class
uh but we've had presidents like that
before and we've survived um I meant
that the president that I think Donald
Trump will most remind people of if he
becomes president is um Andrew Jackson
Andrew Jackson was a general low-class
swore cursed didn't dress well really
not what we think of as a gentleman and
yet he was one of the most powerful and
most important presidents in the history
of America he's the one who really made
American democracy prior to Andrew
Jackson um you know America was a
federal Republican a constitutional
republic and jackson started the
political parties as real political
forces and he started fundraising um he
was the beginning of fundraising for
politics in the United States um he was
the beginning of a populist democratic
le elected president who just terrified
the elites of this country terrified
them and hated them and they hated him
and he did away with the Federal Reserve
the national bank in the united states
that currently the federal reserve
against all their objections when the
Supreme Court told them they couldn't
kick the Indians Native Americans off
their land he said let the Supreme Court
and their army stop me he basically
governed as a populist democratic tyrant
and yet he was so probably the most
popular and democratic president we've
had um we survived that um my hope is
that Trump wouldn't be that bad and we'd
survived him too we may actually get
some good things from Donald Trump just
like there's a lot of good things that
came out of Andrew Jackson's presidency
he's considered one of the most
important presidents in the country he's
on the twenty-dollar bill